d'abord le constat je crois que nous le
partageons avec vous monsieur le
président ce que vous avez dit il me
tuerait parnas bien été observée pendant
l'année 2020 à peu près 90 milliards en
2020 des chiffres pour pour 2021 1 pour
l'instant les prévisions sont
effectivement qu'il y aurait encore un
peu des pins des ménages élevé et on a
même donc une sur épargne qui est même
plus élevée quand on regarde sur la
seule épargne financière puisque les
programmes les projets d'investissement
des ménages ont également été affectées
lors de l'année 2020 par la crise du duc
au vide alors si les chiffres sont en
partie provisoire on peut essayer de
regarder les caractéristiques de cette
de 7 sur épargne
d'abord elle se caractérise par sa
liquidité
dc l'épargné liquide qui a beaucoup
augmenté donc l'epargne à vue et dans
une moindre mesure mais de façon un peu
surprenante les titres également ont
bénéficié de cette sueur ehpad
l'assurance vie en euros qui est donc la
moins risquée mais aussi la moins
rentable a subi une forte décollecte
avec moins 25 milliards d'euros tandis
que l'assurance vie en unités de compte
à augmenter fortement avec + 10 8
milliards d'euros ce qui correspond
d'ailleurs aux orientations des pouvoirs
publics en faveur d'une assurance vie
qui est plus orientée vers le
financement des économies que vers
l'assurance vie en euros celle sur
épargne elle concerne surtout les
ménages les ménages aisés pour le
conseil d'analysé économique qui a fait
des études à partir notamment de données
bancaires de données des comptes
bancaires
les 20% des ménages aux revenus les plus
élevés concentre 70% de l'epargne
supplémentaires cette tendance
correspond aux flux observé hors crise
puisque en 2017 selon l'insee les 20%
des ménages aux revenus les plus élevés
représentaient 68 % des flux d'épargné
capable dé formation
évidemment avec confirmant la baisse de
la baisse de la consommation mais ce
sont les ménages les plus élevés qui ont
le plus épargné
en revanche les 20% des ménages aux
revenus les plus faibles ont vu leur
épargne diminué en 2020 ce qui justifie
pleinement la politique du gouvernement
vers ces populations notamment de
soutien en matière d aide exceptionnelle
aux bénéficiaires du rsa des apl ou en
faveur des étudiants
un dernier point avoir en tête c'est
peut-être regarder un peu les grandes
masses puisque on parle donc de 110
milliards d'epargne supplémentaires
c'est malgré tout limité par rapport aux
voix ce qui est le patrimoine financier
des ménages puisque le patrimoine
financier des ménages c'est environ 4000
milliards d'euros donc là sur épargne
représente 2 75% du patrimoine financier
des ménages
donc je vais maintenant évoquer les
incitations que nous pouvons mettre en
place pour faire en sorte que ces
montants soient le plus utile possible
au financement de notre économie
l'idéal évidemment ce serait que cette
épargne se disent se déverse sur la
consommation afin de soutenir la reprise
dès que l'offre sera moins contrainte
par les mesures de restrictions liées à
la situation sanitaire
la politique très active du gouvernement
en faveur de l'économie de l'emploi doit
permettre de réduire les incertitudes et
et de de permettre de redonner de la
confiance aux ménages pour que il
il consomme donc tout ceci tourne autour
évidemment de la confiance de la fin des
restrictions de l'amélioration de la
situation épidémique est aussi de la
numérisation des entreprises puisque on
consomme aussi de manière digitale et
pas seulement de manière physique
néanmoins au vu de la faible proportion
propension à consommer des ménages les
plus aisés
notre enjeu c'est de réussir à orienter
cette épargne aujourd'hui concentrée sur
des supports liquide vers des produits
plus adaptés au financement de
l'économie en particulier pour répondre
aux besoins en fonds propres des
entreprises pour les banques comme pour
le fonds d'épargné comme pour la cdc
lebane réglementés c'est une recherche
de ressources cher
durablement non compétitive et qui ne
peut pas être investis en actifs risqués
puisque c'est de l'épargné à vue et donc
des français peuvent le retirer à tout
moment il faut donc il ya des règles
prudentielles que connaît que que germe
monsieur mareuse mais qui ne permettent
pas de t'investir dans des actifs
risqués et donc elle n'est pas pour nous
un instrument adapté pour soutenir
l'économie en sortie de crise
je le précise afin de prévenir toute
tentation de livrer qu'ovide qui nous
semble pas un moyen adapté pour faire
face au financement de l'économie en
sortie de crise
quand vous le voyez la question de
l'orientation et de la mobilisation de
la part des ménages est au coeur des
réflexions et des actions du travail du
trésor le sujet est complexe comme je
disais en introduction parce que on ne
peut agir que par l'incitation et que
les comportements d'épargné
d'investissement sont longs à faire
évoluer et dépendent d'une multiplicité
de facteurs ce qu'il dit de notre action
c'est clairement la volonté de soutenir
la consommation des ménages en
garantissant la confiance pour la
reprise et la volonté d'orienter
l'épargné français vers le financement
des entreprises françaises en
particulier leurs fonds propres et en
particulier les pme et les eti
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
directeur madame plagnol maintenant qui
reviendra peut-être sur les préférences
des épargnants français et peut-être les
pistes de réflexion pour mettre
davantage l'épargné au service de la
reprise économique madame plagnol vous
avez la parole pour dire si vous voulez
bien mais merci merci c'est le président
mais c'est le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de nous
recevoir ce matin et
effectivement en complément de ce qui
vient d'être dit je vous propose
quelques éléments peut-être
d'illustrations qui vont tout à fait
dans le sens de l'exposé qui vient
d'être fait d'une part et nous avons
pour l'habitude et pour la 19e année au
cercle des épargnants fait réalisé par
ipsos et un sondage notre baromètre
annuel sur le comportement des français
l'épargné la retraite qui je pense sera
un élément intéressant d'observation en
partie de confirmation de ce qui vient
d'être dit sur le comportement des
ménages et leurs préférences en matière
d' épargne donc assez brièvement je vous
propose de regarder
du point de vue conjoncturel d'abord
nous restons quand même dans un monde
très incertain vous le voyez à travers
cet indice est famille global de
d'incertitude bien sûr nous sommes
retombés par rapport aux moments les
plus critiques de la crise que vivent
mais historiquement nous sommes encore
dans un univers très incertain
et bien sûr ça se reflète dans les
sondages et dans le comportement des
ménages
pour illustrer ce qui vient d'être dit
monsieur là vous voyez à gauche donc
cette hausse inédite de la deûle épargne
des ménages mais elle est assez général
ça n'est pas propre à la france
vous le voyez pour l'allemagne vous le
voyez sur le graphique de gauche pour
l'italie également dans des proportions
assez similaires ce qui nous frappe
toujours c'est que le taux le niveau
d'épargné des ménages en france et
maintenant à des niveaux record en temps
normal j'entends au par deux par rapport
à cette période exceptionnelle et c'est
une constante que nous voyons depuis de
nombreuses années à droite vous avez
l'illustration de ce qui vient d'être
dit je n'y reviens pas la partie compte
courant donc l'accumulation de cache en
fait sur les comptes courants est assez
spectaculaire
plus que sur d'autres produits d'épargné
l'ensemble des livrets réglementés
effectivement été a vu ses comptes
accrue donc nous sommes sur cette
dimension
vous avez évoqué monsieur moules à la
nécessité l'espoir de voir une partie de
cette épargne revenir vers la
consommation et bien je crois qu'on peut
dire que nous l'avons déjà constaté
vous voyez l'augmentation et la
contribution de la consommation des
ménages qui est en gris sur ce graphique
au troisième trimestre de cette année
donc une forte progression
on l'a constaté de nouveau au mois de
décembre donc des quais fectivement les
ménages sont en capacité de consommer
une partie de cet argent qui a été
accumulé de manière forcée comme vos
l'expression revient sur la consommation
ce qui est frappant c'est que bien sûr
tout au long de cette période
particulière la consommation de biens
manufacturés a été particulièrement
marqué alors que et pour les raisons que
nous savons également les services
souffre encore mais là encore dès qu'il
y a une possibilité et pour le dire plus
simplement lorsque les restaurants
ouvrent nous nous précipitons tous leurs
terrasses donc il y a dans cet égard n'a
cumulé je pense un caractère assez
provisoire en partie puisque les ménages
sont prêts à consommer lorsqu'ils en ont
la possibilité
et je pense que nous le verrons à
nouveau le taux dépargne donc a déjà
baissé de ce point de vue vous voyez
nous avions fait un plus haut selon
cette fois ci les chiffres de l'insee à
27 et quelques pour cent et nous sommes
retombés autour de 2 16% 17 % ce qui est
un point assez important à noter puisque
ça nous remet en fait sur une tendance
longue certes nous ne sommes pas revenu
au niveau d'avant crise décembre 2019 le
taux d'épargné des ménages et théâtre 14
9% mais on tend jantes en fait vers ce
set cette norme ce qui est à noter aussi
je pense dans ce débat vous l'avez sur
le graphique de droite c'est
l'importance de l'endettement
l'endettement des ménages
la tendance longue est importante depuis
de nombreuses années l'endettement des
entreprises a progressé également
l'endettement public également
vous le savez je crois bien savoir vous
avez fait un débat là-dessus il n'y a
pas longtemps
il n'en reste pas moins que les ménages
restent inquiets les indicateurs de
confiance le montre avec beaucoup de
clarté d'une part à gauche vous le voyez
les perspectives de chômage sont en
hausse donc lorsque le graphique monde
c'est nous dit qu'en fait les gens
s'attendent à ce qu'il y ait plus de
chômage et c'est bien sûr un facteur
d'inquiétude majeure et ça se traduit à
droite par une intention d'épargné dans
les 12 prochains mois en forte
progression également et qui pour
l'instant continue de marquer ces
indicateurs avec vous le voyez également
et c'est l'effet des mesures qui ont été
prises une capacité à épargner qui est
signalé également en progression
alors voilà pour ces éléments factuels
et de conjoncture d'illustration je
passe maintenant au point fort de notre
baromètre annuel il comporte beaucoup de
d'autres éléments pour commencer
justement je nous avons posé la question
notre précédent baromètre ayant été
réalisée avant la commande est mis nous
avons posé la première question qui
était est-ce que vous avez l'intention
de dépenser et finalement de profiter du
présent puisqu'on ne sait pas de quoi
est fait l'avenir
eh bien nous constatons l'equilibre vous
voyez montre un tiraillement entre le
ceux qui sont prêts à épargner ceux qui
veulent consommer mais on a une forte
augmentation de plus de 4 points par
rapport à l'année dernière
des personnes qui disent vouloir
consommer on voit les gap générationnel
les gaps haussiers en termes de revenus
les personnes de moins de 35 ans sont
plus à même de vouloir consommer et
profiter de la vie
les revenus les plus élevés comme ça a
été dit montre également une propension
à épargner plus importante ça se
retrouve dans ce sondage alors là encore
la prudence et et même la frilosité des
ménages nous la constatons année après
année là
elle est toujours présente elle a
légèrement progressé dans ce sondage
et là encore vous le voyez les personnes
qui sont les retraités les revenus les
plus modestes ceux qui ne détiennent que
10 gréa sont plus enclins à chercher une
rémunération faible mais un une épargne
disponible immédiatement disponibles et
liquides
bien sûr c'est moins le cas pour les
personnes qui ne sont plus confiants
dans leur retraite ou qui préfèrent
profiter du temps et donc des
générations un peu plus jeune donc entre
placement surtout liquide placement
surtout rentable alors là nous avons
quelques éléments un peu contre intuitif
nos jeunes générations semble être
finalement assez enclin à regarder du
côté du rpt et de la prise de risque et
des rendements peut-être un peu moins du
côté de le sg une surprise puisqu'on dit
beaucoup que les millenium sont très
enclin est très soucieux d
investissement et de l'investissement
durable
ça ne se voit pas tout à fait dans ce
sondage je pense que il y as peut-être
quelques arbitrages avoir aidé
confirmation apportée
donc on choisit de placer plutôt très
rentable chez les jeunes pardon est
plutôt très finalement assez responsable
chez les plus âgés mais encore une fois
les portefeuilles ne sont pas de taille
équivalente
la taxation des placements reste un
point central est la question de la
fiscalité des successions et
particulièrement cités grande allergies
en fait à toute fiscalité sur la
succession en matière d'épargné bien sûr
sur le la partie la plus âgée de la
population donc une volonté d'épargner
en fait et je voulais peut-être apporter
une nuance à cette vision d'une épargne
supplémentaire très abondante est
importante
en fait l'intention d'épargner se
stabilise globalement par rapport aux
années précédentes elle n'augmente pas
semble-t-il de manière permanente non on
n'a pas ce sentiment mais plutôt du
caractère un peu de circonstancielle de
cette situation plus que véritablement
une tendance de fond alors même vous
l'avez vu que nous avons déjà des taux
dépargne très élevé en france
ce qui est intéressant aussi et là on
voit un petit peu les effets qu vie
c'est les raisons pour lesquelles on
détient un produit départ alors encore
une fois l'épargné de précaution reste
la plus importante la raison la plus
importante mais elles ne progressent pas
plus par rapport aux années précédentes
en revanche les solidarités familiales
un clic
l'inquiétude pour les jeunes générations
se fait sentir on le voit et cet aspect
là augmente dans notre sondage
par rapport aux autres intentions alors
qu'on a vu monter les années précédentes
l'inquiétude sur la dépendance
il en était moins question dans ce
sondage particulier nous avons parlé
vous avez évoqué les produits les
nouveaux produits effectivement le la
cote du plan d'épargne-retraite
progresse
nous avons fait un focus particulier
cette année sur ce plan alors qu'il est
entré dans notre sondage l'année
dernière et sa croissance et sa
reconnaissance en tant que produit
d'epargne est assez spectaculaire au
regard des chiffres que nous avons même
si vous le voyez mais c'est évident
puisque c'est un produit largement
détenu par les français l'assurance vie
reste en haut du hit parade dans nos
sondages
il n'empêche le per progresse progresse
beaucoup et il progresse même au point
où il est le plus reconnu aujourd'hui
déjà donc c'est la deuxième année que
nous en parlons comme produit d'épargné
pour la retraite c'est à dire il est
véritablement identifié comme le produit
d épargne de long terme pour lequel on
peut se placer juste un élément de
contexte sur les français et la retraite
l'inquiétude reste très forte elle a
progressé à nouveau dans le contexte
aussi qu vide
vous le voyez à 78% les français sont
inquiets sur l'avenir des systèmes de
retraite ça les incite bien sûr à
épargner mais ce que l'on voit aussi
dans les craintes par rapport à la
retraite et là on a un effet qu'ovide
particulier en général la crainte
immédiate pour les actifs c'est de
manquer d'argent et ils ont du mal à
estimer leur retraite avant d'y arriver
là on voit que la notion d'utilité de
socialement 7 l'isolément en fait
provoqué par le cos vide a joué dans
l'intention finalement
de cette crainte évoquée par rapport à
la retraite même si globalement c'est
quand même considéré comme un moment de
grande liberté de possibilité de faire
beaucoup de choses pour les non
retraités dont calculer le montant de la
retraite reste très compliquée et donc
c'est une source d'inquiétude ce qui se
retrouve moins une fois qu'on est à la
retraite et à peu près six retraités
sinon retraités sur dix indique épargné
est ce que cette augmentation est liée à
un effet du confinement il faudrait
vraiment une année de plus pour le
confirmer
je ne pourrais pas conclure
véritablement sur ce point voilà pour
les essais enseignement le financement
du système de retraite donc est une
priorité pour les françaises mais on le
voit les autres les circonstances les
liée à la question du chômage de l'aide
au logement ont pris un petit peu le pas
cette année sur sur ces questions c'est
assez normal au regard des circonstances
donc ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que les français restent quand même très
allergique il n'y a pas d'autre mot à
l'idée de repousser l'âge de la retraite
ou bien de diminuer encore fonds est le
montant des pensions
en revanche ils se font à l'idée année
après année qu'il faudra augmenter les
cotisations voire recourir à des fonds
de pension ceci peut expliquer ou
corroborer bien sûr l'intérêt pour le
per est pour une épargne longue
dans ce contexte spécifique vous voyez
les chiffres sont en très forte
progression sur les deux premiers dit m
donc pour conclure il est clair que les
français pensent à leur retraite ils y
pensent de plus en plus tôt autour de 40
ans on commence à se dire qu'il faut
préparer sa retraite ça veut dire aussi
un horizon de placement très un très
long qui peut permettre effectivement
dans le cadre de d'incitation à
envisagée en fait de prendre et d'avoir
dans ses déplacements des points de
placement beaucoup plus risqué que les
simples assurance vie il n'y a pas un au
départ qui ne soit pas réemployés d'une
façon ou d'une autre
vers le financement de l'économie il n'y
a pas entre guillemets de l'argent qui
dort à la petite exception près des
contraintes obligatoires que nous avons
dû constituer des réserves obligatoires
auprès des banques centrales mais ces
mineurs et ça correspond évidemment des
contraintes que l'on peut bien
comprendre qu'on soit dans le bilan des
banques ou qu'on soit en orbite dans
toutes les banques retrouve son emploi
dans quelque chose soit les crédits à
l'économie de scanning vente soit de
financement des états qu'aux mondiaux
les obligations d'état lorsqu'on est
enfant euros de l'assurance vie soit
dans toute autre destination définies
par les juges et où les opcvm ou voulait
valeurs mobilières que l'on achète dans
la question une question d'orientation
et pas d'une nécessité de quantité c'est
sans doute évident mais je préférais le
rappeler à ce stade les derniers
éléments de cadrage
évidemment c'est le client qui doit
choisir son type d'epargne la vraie
difficulté c'est qu'il faut qu'il soit
correctement éclairer sur commande
irlande qui tue et des choix de leurs
contraintes ou de leurs conséquences
mais c'est évidemment d'abord
fondamentalement une question d'éthique
dans le conseil et cette éthique elle
est supportée par de nombreuses
réglementations notamment n'y fit 2002
qui nous oblige à quelque chose d'assez
jour administrativement mais on va dire
que c'est pour la bonne cause pour
qualifier à la fois le souhait du client
sa capacité ses connaissances et disons
le en deux mots une fini c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui pour aller vers autre
chose que des produits de taux des
produits dits risqués des produits de
fonds propres
il faut plutôt s'adresser à une
clientèle patrimoniale qui ont la
capacité ou en tout cas prouvé
administrativement réglementairement 2
de s'abaisser à ce type de placement
dernier élément de contexte et je
rejoins en cela ce que les deux prix
précédents orateurs ont exprimé il faut
mettre tout ça dans un paradigme de
touba pas depuis la crise mais depuis
maintenant au moins 4,5 en paradigme de
taux très bas
évidemment côté on pas que des crédits
et du coup que débat sifco côté parle et
ça de conséquences structurelles
la première selon moi c'est que il y a
un goût particulier qui s'est développée
pour l'immobilier
pourquoi l'immobilier parce que l'accès
au crédit immobilier avec des taux
structurellement beaucoup plus bas a
donné suffisamment expression une
identité d'emprunteurs gouvernements
solvables que nous n'avions pas lorsque
les taux étaient significativement plus
haut et avec des types de clientèle qui
veulent un maximum de crédit est peu
d'accorder pas et dont vous avez un
phénomène qui se conjuguent d'avoir à la
fois beaucoup de crédits immobiliers qui
se mobilisent parce que c'est moins dans
la tête des clients probablement le
placement y compris pour la retraite
le plus important pour préparer sa
retraite ne plus avoir à payer de loyer
pour pour la suite et ça c'est le
premier phénomène que je dis est ce
culturel est qui n'est pas lié à la
crise qu dit
et puis pour l'epargne qu'itil grèce
n'est pas on nous dit on va dire
financière au sens large du terme
il ya clairement et je rejoins en cela
les présentations ont été faites une
préférence assez globale est assez
moyenne pour la sécurité allait
l'utilité pour deux raisons la première
c'est que nous sommes dans un
environnement d'incertitudes que tout le
monde perd soir au sens très large du
terme et la deuxième c'est que les taux
ne sont pas simplement mal la pomme et
tout est prêt plate et donc pour prendre
des risques ou prendre des durées plus
longues pour avoir une rémunération
faiblement plus élevé et bien en fait il
ya une plus forte pente qui va vers donc
à faire au regard de la liquidité et
ceci explique sans doute avant la crise
qu vide
au fond le poids des dépôts à vue
aujourd'hui dont les bilans des banques
plutôt que d'en de l'epargne
desbois terme qui serait placée à
l'échéance est qu'elle a été la
destination non pas pressenti pour le
futur n'est constatée pendant la crise
parce que nous avons vécu le confinement
nous aiderons puis le déconfinement un
confinement numéro deux vient dé
confinement à l'évidence l'économie
repart à chaque fois très vite et la
consommation avec on a déduit cent en
juin juillet 2020 en la vertu également
sur la deuxième quinzaine de décembre
est donc à l'évidence une partie de
cette plutôt de bons vins sont mutine de
cette sueur et paris nathan une capacité
de libération à la fois matérielle et
psychologique pour retourner vers vers
de la consommation et puis désormais
souligne le ce sont des débats que nous
avons accru nos autorités
nous appliquons naturellement le système
bancaire et nous devons désormais
mobiliser plus des parts dans la
constitution d'un crédit millièmes pour
respecter des critères de deux tonneaux
exactement apparent et donc les banques
consommeront par les recommandations qui
sont faites par le haut comité de
stabilité financière puisse départ de
ménage pour constituer 10 15 20 ou 25%
au projet moulié alors que jusqu'à
présent nous mettions en médecine moment
en crédit à la demande du client contenu
2d niveau très bas de de crédit j'espère
que je n'explose pas mon côté je finis
par deux ou trois remarques ou
considération je voudrais évidemment
dire que la pression de l'orientation de
l'épargné est non seulement légitime
mais elle est très importante et il fait
effectivement il faut regarder ça
régulièrement
c'est une question de la 40 ans une
pétition il ya 20 ans est question
aujourd'hui je perds mes gammes de dire
faisons extrêmement attention pour
autant à la question de stabilité du
système et pour nous qui sont devant qui
on sait que la stabilité du système côté
passif côté parle elle est largement
statistiques et dont il dit à la
constance il faut que le système les
ménages est très confiance dont
l'épargné qui confie aux banques selon
lé retirable et on a la chance
aujourd'hui d'avoir une prise qui n'est
pas accompagnée d'une crise de défiance
sur les systèmes
guerre des banques que se mobilisent sur
le financement de l'économie en plus des
enquêtes d'opinion le montrent les
banques aujourd'hui en une coque de
confiance sur les parts de compiègne
puis cédric en 2018
voilà et ça je dis pas que c'est fragile
mais dont la capacité de financer les
finances et l'économie
c'est au moins aussi important que les
orientations en tant que tel et dont je
voudrais évidemment insisté sur le fait
que dans tous les cas il faut que le
système soit en conscience quelle que
soit la voie où le chemin que les parts
ne me prends pour financer l'économie
deuxième remarque de banques et de
proximité que je suis de mendier
universelle c'est surtout territoire à
tout type de tihan jeu je crois qu'il
faut effectivement participé à un élan
de constance vers la relance vers
l'europe ont pourtant eu des
personnellement je ne pense pas qu'il
faut que des financements soient
qualifiés de relance alors que d'autres
ne serait pas je pense que tous les
financements qu'ils soient du crédit à
la consommation crédit d'investissement
de me faire aider au financement de
fonds propres de tout type de clientèle
sont utiles à la relance de toute
l'économie était donc je ne crois pas je
crois qu'il peut y avoir des billets
offerts à dire qu'il ya des choses qui
seraient plus utiles
finalement à la relance ce que doit être
en tous les cas il ne faudrait pas que
ça se fasse au détriment de l'économie
globale et est au fond un petit peu non
non non lisible qui est celle de tout un
chacun à tout les stands et pardon et
puis troisième remarque jacques latu
monsieur le président je voudrais je ne
peux pas ne pas utiliser ce supplément
pour convenir de ma conviction
personnelle c'est que les systèmes
bancaires ou en bancaires n'ont pas
aujourd'hui vraiment de contraintes
quantitatives pour financer l'économie
on le fait bien on le fait mal c'est un
autre débat mais on n'a pas de
contrainte quantitative là dessus en
revanche c'est une réalité
quelles que soient les critiques ou les
non critiques qu'on formule sur la
régulation prudentielle l aile et
orientale crise est l'élément donc ce
surcroît d'épargnants le compte
évidemment dans les livrets d'épargné
réglementée qui auront collecté en 2020
35 milliards d'euros contre 16 milliards
en 2019 donc c'est une un supplément de
2 19 milliards ce qui est évidemment
très important environ 12 milliards sur
ces 19 sont centralisés à la caisse des
dépôts
c'est un supplément d'environ 12
milliards qui est exceptionnel mais qui
faut néanmoins peut-être relativiser
parce que d'abord 12 milliards c'est 4 %
de l'encours donc c'est pas non plus un
un bouleversement de la taille du bilan
des fonds d'épargné
d'autre part parce que la part des
livrets réglementés dans l'épargné
financière des français est à peu près
stable 9 % en 2020 contre huit et demi
pour cent en 2019 si on regarde les
stocks donc ça ne va pas de déformation
fortes en termes de stocks
et puis relativisée surtout parce que on
observe et je dirais heureusement dans
la deuxième partie de l'année 2020 une
un tassement de ce surcroît d'épargné et
une tendance un peu chaotique
il ya des retours de bâton mais une
tendance à un retour vers les rythmes de
collecte plus proches de la normale je
signalerai en particulier que la fin
décembre nous avons eu sur les livrets
réglementés des sorties très importante
plus de 4 milliards d'euros en une
dizaine de jours à la fin décembre donc
ça montre quand même 7
cette capacité est probablement cette
volonté de revenir à des niveaux de
consommation plus élevée même si au tout
début 2021 nous allons encore avoir des
chiffres de collecte qui vont être
élevés et qu'ils vont surtout paraît
être très élevé puisque l'effet de base
va encore jouer dans ce sens on
on va comparer à des chiffres de janvier
et février 2020 qui était avant la crise
sanitaire
donc il ya une question très importante
c'est très difficile qui est d'évaluer
la part stable de ce surcroît d'epargne
et qui conditionne évidemment son
utilisation de ce point de vue je crois
qu'on a quand même des éléments qui
montrent qu'il y a une part importante
de consommation reporter différé il ya
tout d'abord la vigueur du redémarrage
de la consommation dès que cela est
possible on l'a vu au troisième
trimestre il ya cette tendance à
conserver cette épargne supplémentaire
sur des supports très liquides qui
peuvent être mobilisés rapidement
il ya aussi quelques expériences
historiques même si comparaison n'est
pas raison mais la caisse des dépôts est
une maison qui a une longue histoire
dont nous avons des précédents deux
périodes où la consommation a été gêné
comme ça lors des grandes grèves de 1968
ou 95 tout ça n'est pas très con pas
mais il ya eu une période où il était
difficile de de consommer et donc on a
vu des sorties ensuite assez importante
donc on peut penser que ce sera
également le cas et on peut surtout le
souhaitez alors c'était par une
supplémentaire dont on conte reçu les
livrets réglementés et qui pour une
partie et centralisés à la caisse des
dépôts ce n'est pas de l'argent qui dort
le livret à ce n'est pas de l'argent qui
dort comme on l'entend malheureusement
encore ici ou là c'est au contraire une
ressource qui financent l'économie
réelle dans les limites bien sûr de son
modèle qui est un modèle de
transformation d'une ressource liquide
essentiellement en prêt à long terme
c'est essentiellement un modèle de
prêteurs à long terme et à cet égard la
caisse des dépôts s'est engagée très
fortement dans le plan de relance qui a
été annoncé par les pouvoirs publics
avec la caisse des dépôts a annoncé un
effort de financement en fonds propres
de 26 milliards d'euros sur les
prochaines années dont 20 d'ici à 2022
donc dans des délais très brefs et qu'en
matière de prêts ce qui
concerne davantage des livrets
réglementés le fonds d'épargné
ce sont 75 milliards de prêts qui
devront être déployés au total d'ici
2024 au cours de l'année 2020 nous avons
[Musique]
dû de nouvelle autorisation du ministre
de l'économie et des finances pour
développer et renouveler nos offres de
prêts en particulier sur de nouvelles
doctrines d'emploi qui permet un
élargissement des tests d'emploi des
ressources du fonds d'épargné au profit
en particulier de la transition
écologique et énergétique et du secteur
public local donc toute une gamme de
prêts nouveaux a été mis en place à
partir du mois de septembre 2020 dont
vous voyez c'est très récent et cela
correspond à une utilisation de ce
surcroît des parents dont nous dont nous
parlons avec une tarification améliorée
plus compétitive des conditions
d'éligibilité de certains prêts qui ont
été étendus et plus généralement des
modalités assouplies et simplifier ces
nouvelles offres de prêt vers le secteur
public local et spécialement sur la
thématique de la transition énergétique
recouvre une enveloppe de 12 milliards
d'euros qui est désormais rendue
disponible et dont la commercialisation
a débuté via la banque des territoires
dans les dernières semaines de 2020 nous
avons d'ailleurs deux premiers résultats
puisque notre production de prêts vers
le secteur public local a augmenté en
2020 de 22% par rapport à 2010 neuf donc
c'est un c'est un début et nous espérons
que ce succès va se confirmer et
s'amplifier avec en particulier deux
offres que je signale le n'offrent pour
le renouvellement des réseaux d'eau
qu'on appelle la cua prêt et puis une
offre pour la réhabilitation thermique
des écoles qui est une thématique
évidemment prioritaire avec notre et du
prg et voilà notre mission principale
c'est évidemment et cela demeure vous le
savez le financement du logement social
nous aurons distribué 12 milliards
d'euros de prêts en 2020
dans ce secteur c'est je dois le dire un
chiffre en recul
malheureusement par rapport à 2010 neuf
puisque nous avions distribué un peu
plus de 13 milliards d'euros
donc un recul qui est lié semble-t-il en
grande partie à un ralentissement des
agréments des autorisations d'urbanisme
nous sommes en mesure de faire plus dans
ce domaine nous pourrions développer
notre volume de prêts au logement social
et la ministre du logement a annoncé
vouloir accélérer le rythme de
construction de logements sociaux
le fonds d'épargné de la caisse des
dépôts est tout à fait en mesure
d'accompagner une croissance des volumes
produits dans ce domaine au cours de
l'année 2020 je voudrais signaler deux
éléments plus précis
tout d'abord la collecte importante que
nous avons reçu nous a permis d'investir
beaucoup plus que les années précédentes
en obligations d'entreprises et en
particulier dans la période où le marché
obligataires étaient perturbés voire
fermés pendant quelques semaines à la
fin du mois de mars nous avons pu
investir près de 3 milliards d'euros en
obligations d'entreprises entre mars et
mai dont vous voyez typiquement dans la
période la plus tendue sur les marchés
et où de nombreuses entreprises avaient
du mal à accéder aux marchés
on voit là une illustration du rôle
contracyclique que peut avoir un
dispositif comme le fonds d'épargné
et puis nous avons lancé avec les
compagnies d'assurances une initiative
pour le financement de la relance
nous avons regroupé autour de nous un
certain nombre de compagnies d'assurance
et la fédération des entreprises
d'assurances pour rassembler plus de 2
milliards d'euros d'investissements en
fonds propres essentiellement vers les
pme et le lesotho en privilégiant deux
secteurs qui nous ont paru stratégique
dans le contexte actuel le secteur de la
santé qui a concentré plus de 800
millions d'investissements en fonds
propres qui sont en train d'être
déployés et le secteur du tourisme ou
qui vaut qu'elle a été affectés ont été
affectés plus de 300 millions
d'investissements donc voilà des
initiatives au cours de l'année 2020 qui
ont été permises par ce surcroît de
collecte et qui vont contribuer nous
l'espérons ou relance à la relance et au
rebond de notre économie
merci monsieur le président finalement
n'y at il pas eu un intérêt à travailler
alors ça a été fait il ya des tentatives
de forme de fonds
bon pour effectivement intervenir là
dessus on a indiqué vous avez indiqué
mme cet acteur 100 millions une première
première tranche mais y at-il pas un
intérêt finalement pour l'état à venir
en garantit un niveau 1 niveau à définir
bien sûr sur ses fonds de fonds pour
pousser un peu les investisseurs à venir
sur ces sujets parce que là la question
des investisseurs c'est toujours la
garantie en capital
alors bien sûr on comprend bien que
c'est pas ça peut pas être une garantie
en capital à 100%
mais n'y at il pas là quelque chose à
pousser en termes de garanties sur des
fonds de fonds qui viendraient
intervenir sur les fonds propres des
petites entreprises
question ouverte ok je vous laisse
répondre monsieur le rapporteur général
et puis nous coller j'ai trois questions
la première qui va apporter plus sur la
fiscalité
on voit bien on a on a jusqu'à
maintenant souvent essayé d'orienter
l'épargné vers des ménages vers des
produits jugés comme favorable au
financement de l'économie
je pense notamment s a été également
abordée par un homme plagnol pea et me
en croissance de mon point de vue un
euro croissance est plutôt pas
fonctionné pap me vous semblez dire que
ça frémit j'attends de voir ma question
c'est plutôt de vous demander si
finalement le levier fiscal est
aujourd'hui un outil légitime et
efficace pour orienter le comportement
d'épargné des ménages
d'ailleurs le conseil d'analysé
économique conclut lui que cette pas
tout à fait ce qu'il faudrait faire il
vaudrait mieux accompagner les ménages
plutôt que de vouloir un peu tordre
leurs aspirations
deuxième question qui porte sur la
mobilisation de l'épargné existantes
est ce qu'il faudrait finalement pas
également reconsidérer les règles
prudentielles applicables aux banques et
aux assureurs et à cet instant est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire où en sont les
discussions sur la révision de la
directive solvabilité 2 enfin je pense
que c'est plus passionnant à monsieur
moulin que ma question s'adresse
notamment sur les prêts participatifs
nous avons adopté dans la loi de
finances 2021 des dispositions qui
autorise l'état à accorder sa garantie à
hauteur de 35% pour couvrir les pertes
des secteurs financiers qui investissent
à long terme dans les pme ou eti à sous
forme de prêts participatifs tout ça
dans une enveloppe de
20 milliards d'euros je constate que le
dispositif n'est toujours pas entrée en
vigueur faute d'accord de la commission
européenne pouvez vous nous dire où en
es où en sont les démarches et ne pensez
vous pas qu'il faudrait également
augmenté l'enveloppent puisque moment on
a voté on ne pensait pas où on ne
souhaitait pas d'ailleurs mais on ne se
retourne pensais pas que la pandémie
durerait aussi longtemps
merci monsieur la pente en général j'ai
huit inscrits pour l'instant j'irai
jusqu'à 10 jeux vous lundi que s'il ya
des remords c'est le moment alors rémi
féraud suivi de thierry cozic merci
monsieur merci monsieur le président
j'ai très bref parce que j'allais poser
un peu la question une des questions que
rapporteur général à poser peut-être en
l'élargissant un peu par rapport à
l'ensemble des constats qui ont été
faits aujourd'hui sur la situation de
l'epargne les modalités des financements
de la reprise si on veut aller plus loin
être plus volontariste
est ce que il ne faut pas aussi passer
par une mobilisation publique de cette
épargne privée qui d'abord à toucher ne
concernait d'abord les plus aisés donc a
beaucoup marqué l'accroissement des
inégalités aussi dans cette dans cette
crise sanitaire
est ce que le biais de la fiscalité ou
le biais d'un grand emprunt pour
financer la relance la transition
écologique on a eu la semaine dernière
le débat sur la question de la dette
publique dont on a vu qu'elles posaient
beaucoup de dents jeu mais qu'il n'y
avait pas de sujet de soutenabilité
est ce qu'il n'ya pas par rapport au
financement de la relance et de
des grandes transitions que nous avons à
mener notamment sur le plan écologique à
passer par des démarches beaucoup plus
contraignantes ou incitatives publiques
de grande ampleur pour mobiliser cette
épargne plus utilement que de simples
placements liquides
merci rémi thierry cozic pour lui eric
bouquet merci merci monsieur le
président ma question et s'adresse enfin
il n'y a pas de personnes particulières
à qui elle s'adresse simplement je sais
c'est plutôt un constat aujourd'hui
la phase de sauvetage de l'économie
c'est fait c'est fait à coup de
milliards tour donne dans le cadre du
plan de relance qui ont été distribuées
par l'état
la phase de redémarrage économique à
proprement parler quant à elle ne pourra
se faire sans appel aux marchés des
investisseurs privés à la lumière de la
crise que nous traversons je m'interroge
notamment comment financer le rebond et
permettent aux entreprises de redémarrer
et de manière écologique et sociale et
notamment que ce
il paraît déraisonnable que ce
financement puisque de cette phase de
redémarrage puisse se faire à crédit est
ce que aujourd'hui on n'aurait pas
intérêt plutôt à se tourner vers les
fonds propres extérieur tout à l'heure
on a évoqué les fameux 100 milliards
d'epargne s'en va à dame 10eme 120 130
milliards d'epargne que les français
sont constitués durant la crise
est-ce qu'ils doivent pas être
considérés comme des fonds de guerre et
pouvoir faire l'objet d'une réflexion
dans l'économie par le prisme de
nouveaux produits fiscalement avantageux
et socialement éthiques
à ce titre sensible aux préoccupations
environnementales de nombreux épargnants
ou investisseurs souhaitent avoir un
impact positif sur la planète et
notamment en ayant la possibilité de
souscrire des contrats d'assurance-vie
compte-titres plan d'épargné entreprise
au plan d'épargné retraite qui
contiennent des fonds us air en ce sens
la loi pacte de mai 2019 imposé que les
contrats d'assurance vie multisupports
qui sont souscrits à compter du 1er
janvier 2020 contiennent au moins un
fonds labellisés i et sert green griffin
ou solidaire a compté 2022 ces contrats
devront posséder au moins une unité de
compte dans chacun des trois fonds et
donc ma question est la suivante c'est
quel dispositif vous semble aujourd'hui
opportun les plus à même d'encourager
encore plus le recours à ces clips de
fonds merci thierry rick bloqué puis
didier rambaud
oui merci monsieur le président je
serais j'aurai une seule question elle
sera assez vrai puisque monsieur mareuse
de la cdc a déjà en partie répondu est
ce que je voulais évoquer je pense qu'on
dispose d'un atout avec la caisse des
dépôts et consignations son état est un
autre atout sur les collectivités qui
représente encore 70 % des
investissements publics dans ce pays on
est au début du mandat municipal
il ya les projets les dossiers sont
prêts ou quasiment ou encore préparation
est ce qu'il y aurait pas le moment là
de un peu ce que rémi féraud évoqué un
emprunt exceptionnel faire des
conditions de taux exceptionnel sur des
durées excellent mais monsieur mareuse
nous a dit déjà que c'était possible sur
des dizaines
année s'agissant des collectivités pour
vraiment relancé concrètement l'économie
et en plus les populations sur le
terrain verrait concrètement l'effet
immédiat de ces opérations
eric didier rambaud puis stéphane
sautarel merci monsieur le président
effectivement à la question comment
mobiliser 7 sur épargne pour la reprise
je souhaitais faire puisqu'on est au
sénat fera un zoom sur le lien entre
l'épargné et les territoires créer un
lien effectivement entre l'épargné les
panneaux kalehe et les territoires parce
que je constate qu'il ya quand même de
plus en plus de citoyens qui ont envie
d'investir là où ils habitent et je
prendrai deux exemples que je viens de
découvrir en que le concept de centrale
villageoise
ce sont des sociétés locales qui se sont
créés sur la base d'actions à
gouvernance citoyenne et qui portent des
projets en faveur de la transition
énergétique donc comment justement on
peut je suis convaincu qu'il ya vraiment
un gisement formidable intéressant à
développer donc comment on peut le
comment on peut développer puis l'autre
exemple que vous avez tous vu récemment
avec l'opticien crise pour ne pas le
citer qui a fait le choix de relocaliser
une partie de sa production au d'asie
vers l'est vers les yvelines et à partir
de là comment effectivement on peut
encourager la mobilisation de l'épargné
en faveur de la reprise avec un retour
des industries seront sur le territoire
merci merci didier stephan sautarel puis
emmanuel capus oui merci monsieur le
président
chers collègues merci pour les
présentations qui nous ont été faites ma
question sera sera aussi bref puisque
beaucoup peut déjà été abordés autour
des prêts participatifs
effectivement la mobilisation de cette
épargne pour répondre à une
préoccupation structurelles de notre
économie et de nos tpe de nos pme qui
est pas nouvelle et effectivement la
faiblesse des fonds propres ou quasi
fonds propres pour reprendre les propos
du président reynal peut permettre de
trouver une opportunité de réponse dans
cette dans cette crise pour cette sortie
de crise
et moi je lirai volontiers la question
de l'épargné et l'endettement avec la
sortie dp j'ai eu aussi c'est à dire que
au delà de la mobilisation de l'épargné
est ce que pour certains secteurs
d'activité la sortie dp je ne peux pas
permettre un accompagnement en fonds
propres ou quasi fonds propres des
entreprises via des prêts participatifs
qui permettrait de redonner une capacité
d'investissement plutôt que que de
rester sur un endettement de nous de nos
petites entreprises du coup je fais le
lien avec la territorialisation qui
viennent d'évoquer aussi mon collègue
parce que effectivement le fait de
donner du sens de la visibilité aux
investissements et donc à l' épargne
peut-être via un nouveau dispositif de
fonds régionaux qui pourraient compléter
ce cette approche des frais partie si
des prêts participatifs donc
effectivement avec des conditions
réglementaires et d'assouplissement donc
c'est autour de ce sujet là en fait des
conditions à remplir à la fois pour
donner de la confiance donc
effectivement via peut-être la grande
île étape que nous avons adoptées dans
le plf et comme comme l'a rappelé notre
rapporteur général et qui peut-être
mérite aujourd'hui d'être densifier ou
réinterroger est également en donnant
une traçabilité une lisibilité
à cet investissement à travers une
approche régionale qui permettrait à
l'épargnant de voir vers quoi
en fait et orienter son sens et pas moi
je vous remercie
ainsi stephen emmanuel capus puis michel
canevet voyez merci monsieur le
président il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont déjà été dites donc j'ai bien
compris qu'on avait 100 120 milliards
d'euros dépasse j'ai même entendu qu'on
aurait peut-être 200 milliards si j'ai
bien compris à fin 2021
ce que moi je comprends moins bien c'est
comment on fait pour flécher 20 pour
injecter cette épargne vers l'avenir
c'est à dire vers l'innovation
rémi féraud a très bien introduit la
question tout à l'heure comment on fait
et l'état a un rôle à jouer pour que
cette épargne 7 sur épargne soit investi
dans pas seulement dans la relance mais
dans l'avenir
comment on fait en termes de recherche
collaborative pour ne pas revivre ce que
nous avez vous nous avons vécu ce que
nous vivons quotidiennement notamment
avec valve neva par exemple quand des
sociétés qui ont besoin de 60 millions
d'euros pour investir dans les biotech
préfère aller au zoo en écosse plutôt
que d'investir dans les pays de la loire
celle à laquelle reste les questions
concrètes à laquelle moi j'aimerais
qu'on réponde sait quels sont les
mécanismes nouveaux on peut mettre en
place rapidement pour flécher dans
l'innovation public privé parce que je
pense que c'est là que ça se passe dans
les territoires
nous partageons plusieurs nombreux pour
que nous sortions de cette crise
renforcée avec des nouveaux outils
puisque le constat que nous faisons
c'est que nous avons une épargne qui est
disponible avec des nouveaux outils pour
investir dans notre avenir
merci emmanuel michel canevet depuis
vincent segouin merci monsieur le
président chers collègues j'ai entendu
le directeur général du trésor ne
rappelé qu'il y avait un certain nombre
d'outils à la disposition de l'ensemble
des dispositifs pour pouvoir fonctionner
le directeur de gestion des actifs de la
cdc de dire que des moyens importants
étaient dégagés par la cdc en prêt en
fonds propres et le président de la
fédération bancaire française nous dire
que les banques n'avaient pas de
contrainte aujourd'hui pour financer
l'économie
pourtant on a des besoins extrêmement
significatif
je pense à cinq le nombre d'entreprises
souvent dans des filières ap innovantes
qui ont du mal à obtenir des financement
pour pouvoir mener leurs projets de
développement
je pense aussi aux opérations qui sont
nécessaires pour réindustrialiser la
force et donc mobiliser des financements
sur des filières qui ont été identifiés
le numérique par exemple en études mais
c'est pas la seule l'aéronautique / a
été évoqué tout à l'heure sur lesquelles
des moyens sont nécessaires pour pouvoir
accroître la recherche et la place de la
france dans l'économie mondiale et puis
nous avons aussi il faut le dire très
clairement des problèmes de logement
allez la production de logement dans
notre pays a baissé de 6 7% l'année
dernière est plus grave
le nombre de permis de construire a
baissé de 14 7% ce pays principalement
pour les immeubles
ça veut dire que il y à aussi la des
besoins extrêmement conséquent donc il
faut certainement que l'on soit plus
actif sur l'accompagnement des besoins
des français parce que parmi les
politiques publiques qui ont été
identifiés comme étant celle qui
requiert une action plus voulons aller
c'est bien la question du logement est
donc et notamment l'accès au logement à
la propriété qui est souhaité par bon
nombre de nos concitoyens donc là on
voit bien qu'il y à des actions à mener
pour permettre de lever un certain
nombre de
d'obstacles sur tout ça et sur le
logement juste une petite incidente à la
cdc pour dire quand même que il faut
qu'on fasse attention pour les
financements des les organismes de
logement social sur des prêts à 50 ou 60
ans avec la garantie des collectivités
locales sachant que avant le terme de
ces prêts il faut avoir opéré des
opérations significatives de rénovation
des logements et donc la durée de ses
prêts me semble disproportionné au
regard de la durée de viabilité des
logements alors comme didier rambaud et
stéphane se parle je pense que il y a un
besoin certainement je pense à la cdc en
particulier d'accompagner un certain
nombre d'initiatives locales pour
développer l'achat local pour développer
des actions de verdissement par exemple
autre production d'énergie il irait sans
d'autre à côté de de la mobilisation
n'est pas locale peut-être un soutien de
la cdc à porter pour justement orienté
encore plus les pages locales vers un
certain nombre de deux projets d'avenir
productif pour l'avenir je me dis aussi
que peut-être que l'état compte tenu de
sortie pourrait augmenter le plafond du
livret de développement durable aura
quelques idées merci de les avoir
synthétisé michel vincent segouin est
suivi de vanina paoli gages
merci monsieur le président alors ma
question est plutôt vers monsieur le
directeur du trésor
j'ai entendu dans les propos tout à
l'heure introductif qui avait besoin de
2,2 pouces et les français après
utiliser les pinces de précaution pour
la consommation est sûrement via la
confiance alors ma question c'est simple
parce que vous avez émis des pistes
possibles
vous nous avez parlé de taux négatifs
sur les produits réglementés
vous nous avez parlé aussi de
l'imposition du capital enfin de l'outil
imposition supplémentaire
j'ai en mémoire aussi
la loi sapin 2 qui permet l'imposition
du capital de l'assurance vie alors
qu'elle quels outils réels vous allez
activé pour pour utiliser cette épargne
de précaution ou est-ce que vous allez
tout simplement rétablir la confiance
que les français attendent ça c'était ma
première question deuxième question
c'est vous ne nous avez pas parlé de
l'or ni de l'immobilier enfin si un peu
on dans l'introduction du cercle des
épargnants c'est vrai mais est-ce que si
jamais vous vous allez vers l'imposition
est ce que ça quels seront les effets
sur l'or et l'immobilier
est ce que vous avez fait des prévisions
dans ce sens merci ainsi vincent vanina
paolig agen oui monsieur le président
merci merci aux intervenants pour les
présentations qui ont été faites je vais
en quelques heures de synthétiser
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites par
un certain nombre de mes collègues je
pense que la période est historique pour
reconstruire des pans entiers
d'activités économiques que nous avons
littéralement abandonné depuis trentaine
quarantaine d'années que pour ce faire
chaque euro public devra avoir un effet
de levier maximum sur les euro privée et
c'est pour ça que je pense sincèrement
que cette mobilisation de l'épargné
privée est primordiale elle va définir
en fait le futur de notre pays sa
capacité à avoir toujours une existence
à l'échelon mondial et sa capacité à
donner du travail à ses enfants donc je
pense qu une hybridation entre deniers
publics et deniers privés devraient être
pensé et je voulais sondés sur les
cibles destinataires de ces
investissements qui pourraient être à la
fois public pour aider à la remise à
niveau d'un certain nombre
d'infrastructures dans les territoires
mais aussi privés en consolidant on a
beaucoup beaucoup de pme très innovantes
en france mais qui sont trop petit il
faut il faut faire de la consolidation
il faut faire ce qu'on appelle du du
build up pour créer des acteurs
pertinents
je pense que pour ce faire il faudrait
qu'on se dote de véhicules souverain à
l'échelon de chaque région française
pour essayer de dégager des compétences
d'excellence et orientées comme l'on dit
beaucoup de mes collègues
les pagnes localement pour que les gens
voient en fait où va leur argent et
comprennent que c'est de l'argent qui
est productif pour leur territoire
merci vanina christine lagarde pour
conclure les questions oui merci
monsieur le président alors j'avoue que
j'ai été assez interpellé à part un des
graphiques qui nous a été présenté par
le cercle des épargnants qui est si j'ai
bien compris le ressenti des français
sur le meilleur mécanisme d'epargne et
la croissance très forte délivré afin dé
livres et qui aujourd'hui ne rapporte
pas puisque les taux enfin rapporte très
peu vent on est d'accord que c'est que
c'est sans risque et il me semble qu'en
2020 il ya eu quand même une décollecte
très forte sur l'assurance vie
donc est ce à dire alors même qu'on a
entendu encore ce matin qu' une partie
de cette épargne elle était chez les
ménages les plus aisés j'ai donc une
épargne forcée qui sera qui va pas ce
retrait dire immédiatement par deux la
consommation enfin typiquement si
c'était partir en vacances aller au
restaurant on va pas aller quatre fois
plus en vacances ou dix fois plus au
restaurant quand on pourra y retourner
donc comment est ce qu'on explique que
finalement c'est le livret à qui a
appelé le livret jeune et pas des
placements peut-être un peu plus risqué
mais avec un rendement beaucoup plus
important en moyenne et ce que je
voudrais dire que les français sont non
pas une bonne connaissance des
mécanismes économiques enfin voilà
j'avoue que ce graphique ma à ce
résultat m'a interpellé ce sera donc la
dernière interpellation
mes chers collègues je vous propose de
passer aux réponses alors proposé une
règle du jeu qe2 par intervenant d'être
autour de la moitié du temps de départ
c'est-à-dire autour de cinq six minutes
peut-être à direction d'ittre du présent
europe.com elle a été beaucoup
sollicités
peut-être droit une dizaine de minutes
s'il est si les autres membres du panel
va le bien l'accepter et je vous propose
de le faire à l'envers dans le sens
inverse on va démarrer par olivier
mareuse s'il le veut bien
oui merci monsieur le président pour
revenir sur quelques thèmes qui ont été
abordés
[Musique]
je crois qu'effectivement la question
des normes prudentielles et comptables
applicables aux aux établissements de
crédit et aux compagnies d'assurances
est un point très important pour
l'orientation future de l'epargne parce
que comme on l'a vu les épargnants
français reste on conserve une certaine
aversion pour le risque
quoi qu'on en dise et donc il ne faut
pas enfin il est souhaitable que les
épargnants prennent directement des
actifs risqués pour une part croissante
plus importante qu'aujourd'hui mais il
faut peut-être pas se faire d'illusion
sur la capacité des épargnants à aller
brusquement massivement vers des
supports en actions directement et donc
le système financier les institutions
financières doivent jouer un rôle
d'intermédiation et de transformation et
de capacités donc à partir d'une épargne
sécurisée à investir dans des actifs
plus risqués
cette capacité de transformation elle
est conditionnée prêts largement par le
régime prudentiel et le régime comptable
également d'ailleurs qui ne doit pas
être sous-estimé je pense que les normes
en vigueur qui sont souvent assez
récente d'ailleurs n'ont pas été dans le
sens d'un accroissement de la capacité
des institutions financières à prendre
des actifs risqués on a cité solvabilité
2 mais il ya aussi les discussions en
cours sur les normes bancaires avec le
paquet qu'on appelle bâle 4 qui comporte
des dispositions qui ne sont pas
favorables à
à la détention d'actifs risqués
notamment d'actions et puis les normes
comptables reste également un sujet ce
domaine donc je pense que c'est une
dimension qui ne doit pas être
sous-estimée dans un système encore une
fois d'epargne largement intermédiaire
sur la question du de ce que pourrait
être un grand emprunt moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que que l' épargne
l'épargné réglementée le fonds d'épargné
de la caisse des dépôts c'est un peu un
grand emprunt en permanence un puisque
nous avons les dépôts de 55 millions de
français 55 millions de livret a et du
ldd s avec je le rappelle un encours
moyen de inférieur à 5000 euros et 1 en
cours médian inférieur à 200 euros donc
un produit l'epargne très très largement
diffusés très populaire et et avec
lequel avec ses ressources des prêts à
long terme sont mises en place sur des
thématiques correspondants nous
l'espérons aux priorités politiques
publiques en particulier sur le logement
social sur la transition énergétique et
écologique et plus largement sur le
développement durable avec une
particularité que je voudrais souligner
qui est que les conditions de prêt les
taux applicables sont les mêmes pour
tous les territoires et pour tous les
intervenants quelle que soit leur
situation géographique ou financières
c'est l'unicité des conditions de prêt
qui est une caractéristique très forte
de ceux de ce dispositif sur la durée
des prêts au logement social je
comprends qu'effectivement il puisse
paraître dans certains cas des
engagements très longs notamment pour
les collectivités appelé à les garantir
mais en même temps je crois que ce
caractère très long terme est un
présente beaucoup de vertus et que dans
sa politique de diffusion des prêts au
logement social la banque des
territoires de la caisse des dépôts a le
souci de calais la durée des prêts sur
l'amortissement des des actifs et donc
de ne pas créer
en cours de en cours de route si je puis
dire au cours de l' exploitation des
problèmes de refinancement qui
pourraient mettre en risque les
organismes de logement social en créant
des espèces d'un passe comme ça et
d'obligations d'aller se refinancer à
une période qui ne sera pas forcément
favorable donc notre politique c'est
vraiment d'ajuster de la durée des prêts
sur la durée d'amortissement et de
calibrer cela projet par projet pour
rassurer a le meilleur adossement
possible et en ayant vu l' équilibre ce
que nous appelons dans le jargon l'
équilibre à terminaison c'est à dire la
bonne congruence entre l'amortissement
du prêt et la vie de l'actif financer
c'est un financement par projet sur des
durées effectivement très longue et
c'est aussi la valeur ajoutée de ce
système par rapport à l'offre de crédit
très disponible et très abondantes du
système bancaire c'est que nous nous
plaçons nous vraiment sur des maturités
longues voire très longue c'est une
probablement une des valeurs ajoutées du
système et enfin je voudrais souligner
que les prêts de la caisse des dépôts
sont orientés vers le développement des
projets dans les territoires avec un
taux de retour très important de
l'épargné collectée vers des projets des
différents territoires nous sommes très
attentifs à la répartition de nos
financements à la couverture de
l'ensemble des territoires avec une
présence de nos directions régionales de
la banque des territoires nous avons
gelé 10 des offres qui ont été complétés
par les décisions du ministre de
l'économie et des finances en septembre
en septembre dernier sur des thématiques
prioritaires éducation tourisme
sanitaire rénovation thermique des
bâtiments publics et notamment des
bâtiments scolaires équipements d'eau et
réseaux de distribution d'eau transports
propres
ce sont les thématiques prioritaires qui
ont été retenus et pour lesquels le
ministre a décidé un abaissement du taux
de ses prêts une augmentation de la
quotité pouvant être prises en charge
par par la caisse des dépôts qui a été
porté à 100 % du montant
finançables pour les thématiques
transition énergétique
et puis un élargissement des entités
ayant accès à ces prêts en particulier
en élargissant cela aux agences de l'eau
aux fondations et aux associations
reconnues d'utilité publique et qui
contribue à l'action pour la transition
énergétique et écologique
voilà monsieur le président quelques
éléments de réponse merci monsieur le
directeur monsieur brassac autres grands
transformateurs de court terme en long
terme
et si monsieur le président enfin
j'essaie de prendre en compte l'ensemble
des questions et je me dit deux choses
la première c'est qu'il faut peut-être
en tout cas si c'est la conviction je me
forge décembre il faut différencier sans
doute la question que vous posez
quelques fondamentaux des structurelles
qui aussi savoir si on peut et comment
vous pourrez plus orienté vers plus de
risques hier plus de prise de risque du
système bancaire lorsque ces des crédits
que des épargnants lorsque c'est de
l'épargné longue bancaire pour aller
financer l'innovation pour les finances
et la rse de façon très générale et tout
particulièrement cette question en y
vivent aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya une
question de rebond à sponsoriser et de
romans autrement donc je trouve qu'ils
ont à la question que vous pose est
comment orienter vers cette quantité
nouvelle que l'on de vers le risque et
en risquant plus typé vers quelque chose
d'autre
territorialement on est reçu une
question que jose calif et de
scripturale et que je pense
on peut déconnecter au décor et de ce
que vous appelez comment utiliser cette
aide sur épargne de crise parce qu'une
nouvelle fois et très à plat cette
épargne n'est pas disponible
elle n'est pas en attente de quelque
chose elle et réemployés à cet instant
les plus 60 me harceler des points vis
ruf participent aux puissants 20
milliards de prêts garantis par des tags
qui sont dans dans les bilans des
banques
ma conviction personnelle c'est que
cette sur épargne qui n'était pas saoul
qui est conjoncturelle qui est une
enseigne de crise on aurait tout intérêt
est ce qu'elles reviennent naturellement
vers l'économie notamment par la
consommation le plus vite possible et en
même temps sans rupture en show gêne et
donc qu'on ait quelque chose qui fasse
que sur sur plus au fond ils permettent
de donner une relance
d'abord évidemment par l'économie et
donc par la confiance par la
consommation pendant tout ce qui va avec
et de jeu
je pense que ces deux thèmes peuvent
être distingués je comprends qu'ils
allaient stendhalienne j'ai fait dans la
tête de ceux qui observent le système en
dix ans à peut-être que c'est sur
épargne répondre à la première question
je pense que ce n'est pas nécessaire que
c'est peut-être ma ps1 et que dans tous
les cas la première question se pose
fondamentalement et sur la première
question je voudrais là encore j'ai bien
entendu ce qu'audi g président sur bâle
iii en font un sécurisant le système
bancaire au fonds sécurisé de tous les
acteurs dont les banques et c'est vrai
être toute réglementation prudentielle à
son bénéfice pour les sinistrés mais
globalement mais vous posez la question
quelques sénateurs poser la question sur
sur sur 26,2 sur la réglementation
assurantielle parce que c'est celle qui
est le plus sur les pagnes ambulant je
voudrais vraiment que vous sous-estimez
pas ce qui va se passer avec 24 je n'en
fais pas une obsession personnelle parce
qu'après tout les banques devront
s'adapter c'est le financement de
l'économie qui va faire reconduire le
levier de l'adaptation c'est pas des
banques en temps tellement on a toujours
respecté la réglementation ou moins par
contre en tout temps tel je vous donne
entre autres exemples et gérer les prêts
participatifs tout à l'heure mais dans
le projet bâle 4 le financement des
entreprises non cotées sur un beau coup
plus cotés en fonds propres pas parce
que c'est juste plus prudent mais parce
qu'une nouvelle fois ces réglementations
il faut bien que vous compreniez c'est
aussi en tout d'abord un but
d'harmonisation des règles
internationales entre du système externe
très différents aux états unis
d'amérique la très peu d'entreprises non
cotées et donc tout massacre par défaut
prudentielles mans parce que sans ce
sont chez eux
les entreprises non cotées parce qu'un
des raisons finalement conduire
malsaines en tout cas de risque
particulier au fait de ne pas être cotée
c'est pas le cas en france et donc
appliquer les mêmes évaluations de
risques aux entreprises non cotées aux
états unis et en france dans le meilleur
des cas pas ceux d'hier puis système
bancaire il va adopter la façon de
finalement de financer l'américaine
c'est pareil sur les crédits immobiliers
ne sous-estimez pas le fait que les
bilans des banques françaises est pris
pour moitié par le crédit immobilier à
taux fixe risque de transformation pris
par les banques alors qu'il est
massivement sur les marchés
chez les américains dont d'ailleurs la
génèse mais je n'en fais pas un cas
particulier la jeunesse des fameux
subprimes qui ont été diffusées par le
crédit mobilier qui a été prise et c'est
bien c'est mal c'est même pas le débat à
ce que je dis ah c'est que quand les
réglementations se met en place il ya
deux choses que je voudrais vraiment
faire passer comme message est très
important la première c'est qu'il ya une
harmonisation de fait qui devrait
d'abord renvoyé la question politique
type de financement de l'économie vous
voulez et passer un moment au moyen de
régulation et le deuxième c'est que bien
sûr la régulation et la suède en ciel on
augmente les exigences prudentielles des
banques mais il faut qu'on trouve un
équilibre avec l'intuition que vous
poser c'est comment on fait prendre au
système un peu plus de risques et donc
c'est pas l'un contre l'autre mais on
voit bien qu'il ya un équilibre à
trouver
c'est terrible ça ne peut être que nos
politiques idoines et pas que la sphère
prudentielles et dont je jouerai
vraiment profité de deux voiles à cette
tribune pour dire à cette question est
aussi éminemment politique et évidemment
il est à votre disposition aux policiers
de vous donner des indications près
qu'on traite surtout ceux ci merci merci
monsieur le président je voudrais vous
rassurer ça sera sans doute avec le
reportage un drap l'un des thèmes futur
de s'intéresser effectivement à cette
question est ce que vous appelez bâle 4
ce que le gouverneur rappelle là
profitent de bâle iii donc mais bon mais
en tout cas des sujets posez vous plaît
sont importants et et nous en
reparlerons et je pense que la direction
du trésor sera également sollicitée
sur cette question très bientôt nous
poursuivons avec madame valérie plagnol
et nous laisserons faire si je peux me
permettre la voiture balai à la
direction du trésor pour reprendre dès
que les questions qu'ils n'auraient pas
été auxquels ils n'auraient pas été
répondu par les précédents orateurs
merci monsieur le président merci pour
toutes ces questions là aussi je vais
devoir répondre de manière un peu
général pour se plier du graphique qui a
interpellé madame la sénatrice je crois
que je n'ai fait qu'illustrer ce qui a
été dit par tout le monde c'est à dire
qu'effectivement cette épargne a été
parqué sur des comptes courants et nous
l'avons vu
d'un point de vue plus général je
voudrais rappeler quelques points
en commençant par le fait et ma position
du côté des ca des épargnants mi mai un
vide particulièrement la question de l'
épargne se comprend surtout comme un
projet de vie pour un épargnant qu'est
ce que je vais faire de mon épargne pour
quoi faire et quand et moins sur la
question finalement d'un projet de
rendement ou même un projet d'impact la
réalité c'est pour quoi faire pour moi
et pour la suite de ma vie c'est comme
ça que les gens on voit des choses ça
explique je pense en grande partie dans
le contexte actuel cet attentisme que
nous avons tous constaté et qui est lié
bien sûr à la difficulté de se projeter
dans l'avenir
l'inquiétude pour soi même mais aussi
pour les siens le sondage le montrait et
ça c'est face à la fois la situation
pandémique bien sûr la teinte aussi il
faut bien le dire en matière de
l'augmentation de la dette publique et
de la fiscalité qui pourrait arriver
ultérieurement
c'est on appelle les équivalences
reatard et ricardienne elles sont assez
bien connus et documentés en économie
nous l'avons dit également la baisse
constante des rendements
un pesé et pèsent encore sur aussi les
choix en matière d par la nécessité de
sécuriser en quelque sorte ses revenus
d'épargné à long terme pour soi même et
pour sa retraite
donc la question est là je rejoins ce
qui vient d'être dit l'importance des
conseils de l'intermédiation et tout à
fait capital pour les épargnants mais
bien sûr aussi la question de la
fiscalité en matière de confiance
la clarté la simplicité la constance
moi j'allais dire presque le niveau de
cette fiscalité ils sont importants pour
les épargnants on l'a vu à travers la
mesure du père fut qui par sa simplicité
a montré aux épargnants et de l'auto dé
le taux n'est pas nul
loin de là que finalement c'était un bon
moyen de ramener les épargnants vers
peut-être une épargne plus risqués
donc je crois que ça c'est le premier
constat qui ne faut pas oublier et le
deuxième c'est que l'orientation de
l'épargné dépend en fait il ne peut pas
se comprendre dans un contexte isolé
mais il dépend aussi du contexte
économique propre à notre pays et nous
avons de ce point de vue un problème
d'organisation de notre économie
il faut bien le dire et c'est difficile
quelquefois entendre mais la question de
l'organisation du travail du coût du
travail
je prends ma casquette d'économistes je
fais aussi douter de la réalité dure la
relocalisation
c'est un sujet dont on parle beaucoup
mais en aurons nous les moyens
serons-nous compétitifs par rapport même
à nos voisins immédiats pas seulement
lointain mais en europe même la question
de la formation des personnes tout ça
participe effectivement d'un processus
de confiance à plus long terme qui
relance à la fois la consommation mais
aussi cette confiance dans la volonté
d'épargner pour le long terme et de fait
être capable grâce aux conseils à
l'intermédiation de prendre plus de
risques merci madame nous allons donc
conclure
cette audition en redonnant la parole
emmanuel moulin qui nous a dit en
introduction que par rapport à il ya 40
ans il ne dirigeait plus l' épargne mais
il ne pouvait que l'orienter essayer de
l'orienter mais j'ai senti qu'on avait
dans la salle des sénateurs d'une
génération qui croyait encore que le
trésor pouvait réellement organisé
l'épargné des français
vous allez devoir répondre à cette
interrogation
merci merci monsieur le président je
voulais faire peut-être de remarques
préliminaires sur un point qui a été
évoqué par mme plagnol est entendu par
monsieur brassac
le premier c'est que effectivement je
crois que ce qui est très intéressant
dans le sondage du cercle des épargnants
c'est que ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il n'y
a pas une modification dramatique du
comportement d'épargnant à moyen terme
d'aidé des ménages est en fait
clairement ce qu'on a constaté en 2020
c'est une sur épargne qui est très
clairement liée à l'impossibilité de
consommer c'est à dire que on a eu un
maintien à peu près du revenu disponible
brut des ménages qui a baissé peut-être
de 0,5 on n'a pas encore les chiffres
définitifs pour pour 2020 et on a eu une
baisse de la consommation de 7 % donc
par définition tout ce qui n'a pas pu
être consommés s'est retrouvé dans
l'épargné quand on regarde trimestre par
trimestre normalement il ya à peu près
370 milliards par trimestre de revenu
disponible brut 313 milliards à peu près
en moyenne de consommation et 55
milliards d'épargné et au deuxième
trimestre de 2020 on avait à peu près le
même chiffre en matière de revenu
disponible brut
mais on avait quasiment 60 milliards de
moins de consommation et donc une grosse
somme une épargne qui a doublé par
rapport à la moyenne trimestrielle du
deuxième trio
je dirais aussi par rapport à ce qu'a
dit monsieur brassac c'est qu' il est
clair que toute cette épargne à les
utiliser et donc la capacité de
financement des ménages quand on regarde
d'un point de vue macroéconomique elles
se retrouvent pour financer le besoin de
financement des entreprises qui a
beaucoup augmenté
et puis évidemment le besoin de
financement de l'état puisque le besoin
des besoins de financement de l'état ont
particulièrement augmenté j'y reviendrai
vous m'avez posé des questions très
précises sur les négociations avec la
commission européenne sur les prêts
participatifs
donc vous avez effectivement votée dans
la loi de finances 2021 un programme de
prêts participatifs dans le cadre du
plan de relance qui permet de mobiliser
20 milliards d'euros de financement pour
les entreprises afin de leur offrir des
financements de long terme pour investir
et se développer sans impliquer une
modification de leur gouvernance est ce
que vous avez souligné monsieur le
président que monsieur le rapporteur
pardon pardon monsieur monsieur rapporte
à générac
effectivement il n'ya pas de deux pas de
volonté bien souvent des dirigeants des
entreprises d'ouvrir leur capital et
sera était d'ailleurs compliqué de
demander à l'ensemble de ses
investisseurs de devenir actionnaire
proprement dit donc c'est pour ça que
nous avons souhaité faire ce dispositif
de prêts participatifs avec donc le
soutien de l'état qui prendra la forme
d'une garantie aux investisseurs une
garantie de premières pertes comme ça a
été soulignée et les prêts seront
distribués par les réseaux bancaires des
entreprises viables sur la pâle blast 2
sur la base d'un plan d'affaires ou
d'investissement garantissant
l'intention des entreprises d'utiliser
ces financements pour se développer donc
c'est c'est le relais en quelque sorte
de l'urgence des pge qui étaient des
instruments plutôt de trésorerie de
soutien à la trésorerie et on passe le
relais à des instruments qui permettent
le développement et la reprise d
entreprise alors la commission a accepté
de considérer ce dispositif comme un
soutien à l'investissement pouvant
déroger à certains paramètres de
l'encadrement temporaire sur les sur les
aides d'état
formés mais faute de cadre différent on
reste quand même dans un cadre de
référence qui est celui du cadre
d'emplois temporaires liées à la crise
du colis les 10,6 des discussions elles
se sont concentrées sur les propositions
et les paramètres de ces de ces
dispositifs
d'une part la durée du dispositif on
voulait garantir des prêts jusqu'à fin
2022 alors que l'acaa dormant tant peur
ne permet de de faire des opérations
avec une aide d'état jusque jusqu'au 31
décembre 2021
et puis la maturité des financements on
avait proposé 10 ans et l'encadrement
temporaire limiter les dispositifs à 6
ans donc on nous avons discuté
enfin nous avons des longues
négociations et la commission a accepté
d'approuver un dispositif qui serait mis
en oeuvre jusqu'au 30 juin 2022 donc au
delà de la limite du 31 décembre 2021 et
pour des prêts accordés à des pme et
désobéit d'une maturité maximale de 8
ans donc on a réussi à transiger entre
les dix ans que nous souhaitions les six
ans qui était la limite et donc on est
arrivé à 8 ans donc on est en train de
mettre en place ce dispositif on attend
encore donc l'accord formel delà de la
commission on a préparé le décret de
mise en oeuvre des prêts participatifs
il a été présenté au ccrf fait l'objet
d'un dialogue constant avec avec les
banques avec les investisseurs et avec
la fédération française des assurances
qui nous a dit que les assureurs étaient
intéressés par un produit garanti dont
le rendement sera attractif dans
l'environnement de taux actuels sur vous
m'avez interrogé sur solvabilité 2 sur
la révision de la directive solvabilité
donc cette révision allait débuter en
février 2019
elle a été légèrement retardé par le
contexte sanitaire
l'eiopa qui est l'organisme de
supervision de l'assurance au niveau
européen rendu un avis le 17 décembre et
la commission devrait proposer un
nouveau texte à la fin du premier
semestre 2021
plutôt que fin 2020 et donc il sera en
cours de négociation lors de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne ce qui peut être un avantage
est aussi un inconvénient puisque la
présidence à une devoir de neutralité
mais nous pourrions nous pourrons nous
serons très attentifs aux évolutions et
en particulier comme vous le savez nos
principales préoccupations concernent le
traitement prudentiel de
l'investissement à long terme dans
l'économie et en particulier le
traitement des investissements en
actions qui sont aujourd'hui extrêmement
pénalisées par la directive solvabilité
2 et quelques exceptions que nous avons
négocié mais nous souhaiterions aller
plus loin et l'amélioration de la
surveillance des activités
transfrontalières et de la capacité
européenne à gérer des difficultés dans
le domaine de dans le domaine de
l'assurance
troisième point sur lesquels vous m'avez
interrogés c'est sûr c'est sur la
fiscalité je voudrais répondre à
monsieur le sénateur je n'ai pas eu
d'augmentation d'impôts ni d'imposition
à aucun moment je tiens le clarifier
nous l'orientation qu'ils avaient des
qualités celles de ce gouvernement c'est
mettre en place un prélèvement
forfaitaire unique et donc d'avoir une
forme de neutralité de la fiscalité à
l'égard des différents placements avec
certains avantages particuliers est
assez spécifique mais l'idée c'était
d'avoir un prélèvement forfaitaire
unique sur l'ensemble de l'épargné qui
permettait les l'objectif essentiel
c'est est de diminuer la surtaxation la
très forte taxation qui pesait sur les
produits notamment en action puisque les
taxations des actions étaient
extrêmement forte
je je je je me dépêche que j'évoque de
de trois sujets qui ont été évoqués par
les par des sénateurs donc sur l'épargné
locale la relocalisation évidemment
sondés sont des préoccupations qui sont
importantes qui ont qui sont importantes
pour nous dans le cadre du label relance
nous souhaitons nous avons demandé un
reporting sur l'ensemble des
investissements qui seraient faits qui
seraient réalisés sur les territoires et
ce label orient entre l'investissement
en particulier vers l'est vers les pays
et les pme françaises et donc on aura un
reporting sur le les investissements
dans les territoires vous avez évoqué
sur les territoires aussi la nécessité
de se doter de véhicules souverain au
niveau national en l1 c'est la bpi qui a
un rôle extrêmement important dans le
financement des entreprises que ce soit
en prêt ou en fonds propres et qui est
un catalyseur d'investissement en fonds
propres dans les entreprises les pme les
start up
il ya beaucoup de fonds qui ont été
constituées qui vont de la grande rue de
la grande entreprise vraiment à la plus
à la plus petite sur l'idée d'un grand
emprunt
la réalité c'est que eelv et malheureuse
a dit que la caisse des dépôts est un
grand emprunt à elle seule effectivement
et l'état est aussi un grand emprunt à
lui tout seul puisque lors de l'année
2020 le besoin de financement de l'état
a été augmentée est passé de 230
milliards à 360 milliards clairement le
plan de relance de 100 milliards d'euros
c'est un grand emprunt c'est un grand
emprunt puisque il y en a 40 milliards
qui vont être financés par l'union
européenne mais la 60 milliards qui sont
financées par l'emprunt
puisque on n'y a pas eu d'augmentation
d'impôts on a plutôt tendance à
continuer la baisse des impôts et donc
c'est bien l'emprunt qui finance ses
priorités dans les priorités qui sont
celles du plan de relance j'y reviendrai
pas parce que vous ne connaissez pas
très bien et que vous l'avez vous
l'avait votée dans le cadre de la loi de
la loi de finances il ya évidemment tout
un aspect qui est relatif à la
résilience de l'économie française et
qui touche à la fois aux relocalisations
à l'accompagnement des entreprises
lorsqu'elles ont des investissements de
relocalisation nous avons tout un
dispositif de financement
d'investissement de relocalisation nous
avons évidemment des dispositifs de
financement de la recherche et de
financement de l'innovation en
particulier je pense dans des nouvelles
technologiques soient l'hydrogène les
biotech etc ou les la microélectronique
donc je dirais que ces préoccupations là
elles sont elles sont bien appréhendé à
l'intérieur du du plan de relance sur
l'île et sert c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement important et qui est
extrêmement important pour le ministre
qui a très fortement conscience que les
épargnants cherchent à donner du sens à
leur épargne et donc le label y
laissèrent que vous avez mentionné en
particulier pour les sciences vie c'est
quelque chose qui a très bien marché
puisque le nombre
de fond qui sont labellisés ysl a doublé
et on est passé d'un encours de 150
milliards à 300 milliards
depuis que nous avons mis en place ces
dispositifs
je eu je crois que il y avait une
dernière question de madame là-bas sur
l'attractivité du livret a fait le
livret a et le ldd
ils sont très bien rémunérées en fait
pour des pour des placements garantis à
vue en fait quand on est dans un
environnement de taux négatifs avoir 0
5% sans impôt dessus
c'est une très bonne rémunération et
doudou l'attractivité du livret a je
pense qu'il n'est pas souhaitable
d'augmenter les plafonds ça avait déjà
été fait en 2012 pour le livret a il
nous semble que les emplois qui peuvent
être utilisés par le livret à qui est
une ressource chers comme le comme le
ldd ne sont pas suffisants pour
justifier une augmentation du plafond du
ldd
[Musique]